Hello everyone, this is Frank DiFrates, and welcome to HoloTalk, the Internet's laser and holography talk show enjoyed in over forty-two countries throughout the world.
And now, here's this week's show.
Hi, Mark, it's Frank Defratus.
Hey Frank, how are you?
Doing pretty good.
Good to finally talk to you.
It's great to talk to you.
And I've been reading uh all the Holo Talks or listening to the Holo Talks for uh gosh, since you started.
With with your twenty-seven years that you've been been involved with this, even if we were to condense each year down to a minute, we're still looking at a half hour.
So that's funny.
To go back twenty seven years, I mean, people that are listening to the show, number one, a lot of them weren't even born yet.
Okay.
And number two, you're going back to a time when you just didn't go out and purchase a laser and go in your basement and do holograms because it was such an expensive purchase.
I mean, it was a thing of almost science fiction twenty-seven years ago, on the street at least, not to us, but on the street.
What got you started in this?
Well, I guess I saw my first hologram when I was twelve years old at an art festival down here, and they were from the Smithsonian.
They were transmission types.
So they're all played back by laser.
My dad took me to the show.
And the thing that totally knocked my socks out, I was a photographer at the time.
And uh was the fact that there was a a picture of a book with a magnifying glass, and you could actually move around and see the magnifying glass lens the words in the book.
That didn't make any sense to me as a photographer.
I kind of stashed at the back of my mind.
And then fast forward about four or five years, I read an article in the New York Times written by a lady named Peggy Sealphon, a photography writer, about the New York School of Holography opening.
And I just decided, well, you know, damn the torpedoes, I need to go and find out what that's all about.
Yeah.
And so I got on a plane and went up there and uh and studied and uh just got bitten by the bug.
Was that that one of those first exhibits that was in New York at the time?
Well, the very, very first exhibit was before the museum per se uh was around and it was over at uh I uh uh International Center of Photography.
Yeah.
But uh it wasn't so much an exhibit, but they were teaching down in the basement where later Dan and Sam so famously taught on thirteenth Street, New York School of Holography.
It was Posey Jackson and Jody Burns and uh were running it and uh although they weren't my instructors or anything.
So I came back and I built a little I told my mom, you know, I was gonna buy a laser and and she had, you know, visions of Doctor No and you know, James Bond and all that and thought I was gonna burn a hole through the house.
This is the early seventies, right?
Yeah.
And uh so uh got a laser, built a little laser lab, started re uh redoing all the experiments that I'd read people had done that I just couldn't believe the results of so that was a lot of fun.
Then about six months later went back to New York with the stuff this is before the museum opened and I showed some of the stuff to to Posey and you know, she kinda flipped out in a positive way and sent Jody off to find me some giant Ag for plates.
To me they were giant, they were eleven by fourteen inch plates.
Yeah.
I said, Do this this size, we want to show this at the opening of museum holography.
And I was like, Oh my god, you know, I've never seen a plate so big in my life.
I'd been working with eight by tens and four by five.
Yeah.
And uh one piece in particular that they like, although we ended up showing three at the museum's opening and and I helped around there, sweep the floors, bolt the w you know, sign on the wall and you know, tweak lasers and secure lasers, scurry scurry around Edmund Scientific across the across the river and trying to find the bits and parts we could cobble together what we needed to to to show off the big transmission types that were on loan to the museum, which were oh we're just a joy.
I mean, the big uh portrait of Gabor everyone's seen, the police portrait and some of the classic Fritz Goro stuff and some of the m early McDonnell Douglas stuff.
You know, you know meter some odd size transmission types which at the time seemed you know gargantuan.
So we set those up to playback by laser along with all the rest of the stuff at the museum and it was a very heady time because uh uh well for gosh sakes for me it was like home because out here on the peninsula there was nobody doing this between here and New York.
And uh so it was like home to me the fact that a place actually gave me and the work and the medium enough respect to uh to establish a uh you know a museum.
I was just really touched by the whole thing and it was it was very uh it was wonderful.
Did you have a piece in that inaugural uh tour I think it was it was called Through the Looking Glass or something when the museum first opened Yeah, well the first opening show down there uh uh at the museum there were three one was Curved Space Time.
Uh one was Holo Dolly, uh a holographic uh um uh portrait of Saladali as frozen inside this multifaceted crystal.
And the third one was something called uh the geometric optical graphic design is observed new crystal bobble floating in foreground.
And basically it was a hologram where this giant multifaceted bobble did flo float about a foot in front of the plate and you could walk up to it and uh and put your eye out to it and see this geometric design behind it being lensed like hundreds of times through the bottle.
So it's lensing function was was captured.
I believe it in that first show we did a lot of uh placing of uh little stickers on the ground, uh where uh sort of like you know uh those games where they show you how to tango or whatever.
Oh okay.
And where where to put your feet or whatever.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it was kind of instructions on how to look at the hologram because people weren't unfamiliar with how to address the space.
Yeah.
We're so used to we've gro grown up, you know, with this whole Lascow Gutenberg tradition of everything is either on the cave wall or in the book or on the TV screen, everything is flat.
And so uh you have to kinda r relearn how to look at the universe as a multi dimensional entity that that it was in the first place when you were born.
Well, y you know, from my observations being out uh at exhibits, I think we could still use those footprints on the floors now.
Oh yeah, no no, especially with projected images.
Oh yeah.
You know, projected images are are uh a situation where you don't know what to expect if you're not, you know, savvy.
Yeah, that was an early show.
Trying to think of the year, it was probably mid seventies or so.
'Cause I remember uh I went down, I had a car that had one of the windows was broken out and I had plastic on the window and there was no heat in the car, so we were wrapped in blankets as we waited in the parking lot.
We don't know from that down here in Miami by the way.
Yeah, yeah.
We'd know it today up here.
Interesting.
Um yeah, so you do a lot of other things.
Now I'm gonna have a link to your website.
Oh, that's sweet.
You know, along with the uh the show as well.
So when people come to listen to the show, and in fact if you're listening to the show now, there's no reason to sit there and just stare at the computer.
You know, real player will play in the background.
So if you go back on the Holo Talk page and click on the diamond images link, you'll be able to go right to the website while you listen to it as well, you know, providing you can do two things at once, which most of you I assume can.
Um to move on, uh you've always been in Florida, I guess then, right?
Well, based here, yeah, I've worked in different places, but I I'm based here in Miami and I'm kind of a a tropic, subtropical kind of guy, and don't really want to shovel snow.
Yeah, they they uh visitors definitely have to go onto your experience page as far as you where you list all the things that you've done.
I mean, you've been a photographer for Rolling Stone magazine back in the days.
I imagine it was the newspaper back then, because I remember getting a lot of things.
Yeah, it was a newspaper format, that's correct.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, I've done photojournalism in in many years, yeah.
That was uh kind of grew up telling stories with pictures, you know, using two dimensional images.
But when I bumped into holography, it opened up a whole other uh realm as you can imagine.
Yeah.
Well this this is the real deal with you.
I mean, a lot of the people that uh listen to the show are are amateurs and hobbyists, you know, and Oh, I can address amateurs and hobbyists.
Oh, sure.
I'm absolutely but uh you really I can tell them the one most inspiring thing that I've discovered.
Great, go ahead.
It doesn't make any difference whether you're fifteen years old, eight years old, or fifty-five, or eighty years old.
The next Dr.
Dennis Gabor, the next discovery of significant import, perhaps a window into yet another dimension, will come from someone, regardless of their age, who's paying very close attention.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
And that's the interesting thing, uh, throughout the history of science and the whole so-called serendipitous discoveries and and that sort of thing.
Somebody was paying real close attention.
And uh uh that's one very interesting factor that you don't need to have all the degrees and you don't need to necessarily be doing this ten years or twenty years.
You might be doing it in the case.
As a science to our project and stumble upon something if you're paying close attention to realize what it is you've stumbled upon.
Yeah, yeah.
And with some of the new light sources, I wouldn't be surprised if we see something come down the plate quickly that uh takes the place of the laser piece.
I mean I know we've moved into the laser diodes, but when you start to look at some of the LEDs and things of that nature, I wouldn't be surprised if they start to get down to where they have such I'm totally fascinated.
I've been kind of predicting that for about ten years ever since I had a student who worked for Opera Electronics Division of uh uh Hewlett Packard out in Palo Alto come in one day when I was teaching on San Jose and he and he and he handed me a handful of diodes that were at the time in the red range and they were very narrow bandwidth maybe about ten nanometer wide and he was telling me that you know the blues were coming and the all yellows were coming and this was like twelve years ago.
And at that point I realized that perhaps it would be a resurgence in transmission types based on the fact the light sources were going to cost a dollar versus you know five hundred dollars or a thousand dollars.
And I think that's something that hasn't really been properly exploited yet but now that you guys are uh promoting things like shoe box holography and the diode stuff I have a feeling that uh that that's going to be an obvious uh benefit of of uh of cheap n uh coherent or of these monochromatic sources is is the resurgence of a transmission type.
Yeah I love transmission holograms.
I love transmission holograms.
Yeah.
I've been illuminating a thirty by forty centimeter laser transmission hologram down here now with a uh a red LED that I got from Walmart that costs like a dollar ninety nine.
Very interesting.
Yeah and it's it's it's bright, it's incredible.
Yeah.
What what what projects are you working on now?
I know if they uh when when people go to your website they'll be able to see some of the ones that you've uh worked on.
The Dizzy piece I have the Dizzy piece I you know uh down here working there's always uh Coltrane, uh uh Parker, Monk and Davis on, you know.
So uh I have the holograms?
No, no, music.
Oh music.
Yeah, I want to see that John Coltrane.
Yeah.
Uh going back to the Dizzy hologram, how did you get involved with that?
Well, um Dizzy uh in terms of the creation of the hologram and everything.
Um originally um I I went to see him and I uh perform here and I I'd seen him a couple times and never really talked to him and uh I've been doing a series of holograms ever since like the mid late seventies, uh of folks that I really admired and he was one of 'em and and uh actually really changed a lot in terms of music and and awareness of the certainly the Afro um realm of uh Athro African rhythms and stuff integrated into into some of the so called modern music and anyway I I really admired him.
I went and turns out he was a shutter bug, uh he was really into photography a lot.
And I showed him some holograms and and I asked him uh if uh he would sit for me and he said sure, why not?
And as it turned out, um he was going to California the next day and I was going to California the next day too 'cause I was working on a hologram that we we mounted aboard a uh private jet.
Mm-hmm.
And so I was going out there to work on the model for that and and he was going out there, so we decided to do it out there.
And um uh uh that was the genesis of it basically.
I asked him if he would sit for me and he said, Yeah, let's do it.
Yeah, so you you do that from start to finish then at those pieces, right?
Well I I what do you mean?
I mean I I'm patterned it at a facility in Van Nyes at the end of the year.
Yeah, the the f the film capture uh again.
Oh, sure, yeah.
Sure.
But for instance the output of it was done uh I filmed it with Greg Newswanger and Van I's uh back in uh gosh, I don't remember the year really.
But uh we were in a facility that they had, I think at the time they called it um I wanna say A D D but I know that that's something that they but that's something else these days.
Uh it was called advanced dimensional displays, I believe.
And it was a company that Craig and uh Chris Outwater had had uh basically spawned after they unplugged from Disney uh that beautiful facility that they put together for for them.
And uh so it's very interesting how sort of sideways uh Disney kinda spawned the creation of the of the system that that that you know was making those giant holograms out there.
Now of course John Perry's the master, you know.
Uh uh I think uh hands down as far as I'm concerned.
What's the square footage of your lab?
Your facility.
I had put a facility together uh a few years ago.
The last one I put together was like three labs.
Uh huge and uh it was ten thousand square feet.
And uh and we unplugged that lab and now uh without the overhead of all that stuff, I can work independently, uh with much greater fluidity.
I found that over the years people who had labs specifically set up to do one particular thing um had a tendency to well, only do that thing and f uh honestly with there's so many different types of holograms that uh any given project may re uh require a specific type of hologram and uh it's very hard to maintain a facility that does all of them well.
Yeah.
So now I have incredible uh uh um autonomy in terms of of of specifying uh what is required for the project and like I did a project uh year ago with this uh I guess it's world's first smelling hologram uh which I shot out with Eve Gentet out in uh in Bordeaux and he of course is the fellow who's been lauded as creating one of the best uh full color emulsions yeah yeah and uh but uh by circumstance that was appropriate for this particular project the smelling hologram he happened to have a pulse laser uh uh Ruby there as well as this other rig for creating the full color stuff so they both worked very well because I needed to uh together because I needed to freeze these uh candies in space for this project and red hots and while I had tried all kinds of doing it that's a great piece uh the best thing to do is just to fly the candy in space grab it with the pulse Ruby laser and then transfer that master to a white light fuelable reflection type.
That was ultimately in the end the best way to do it and so now I can specify where to go for and just basically shepherd the project uh in in a facility that doesn't belong to me.
You know that I won't build another lab, it's just that for the moment um I find a phenomenal autonomy and and much lowered overhead on a day to day basis.
Yeah let me just remind the listeners that these holograms that we're currently talking about, both the Dizzy and and the Red Hot are uh both available on your website for sale.
Um go over there check them out and uh I'm not quite sure.
I don't I didn't see a price on the Red Hots, but I know it's a l a limited edition of seven or something, right?
Right.
But the uh Dizzy's an open an open edition?
No, no, no.
No, it was.
Oh, you mean the giant one?
No, the uh the little one, yeah, it's pretty much open.
Absolutely.
And those are I think twenty bucks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course.
If you sell a bunch of those, that's nice, huh?
Yeah, it's a piece of history.
It's fun.
Uh you know, I always expected uh uh a time would come when when we have this sort of democratization uh of the art form in the sense that you know why do does someone have to spend a hundred or a thousand or ten thousand dollars for a a a really nice piece of art uh in this medium that's for twenty bucks bam you're in.
And uh I think that's the way it should be honestly I think all the best holograms in the world need to be remastered for uh in a version that can be purchased for twenty bucks.
Oh yeah yeah you go into some of the holography shops and you'll see a four by five piece of film in there for like fifty bucks and someone will buy one you'll never get them back to buy a second one.
Or that magic number that you see always on TV nineteen ninety five yeah nineteen ninety five yeah that hologram God bless you for that hologram you did of the uh Gloria uh I I I'd have to have a fan on me and go outside and get some fresh air shooting that.
Yeah she's she's a poppin' thing.
Yeah.
And the uh stereoscopic view uh on your web page is cool too because things in three D isn't it?
Yeah yeah.
Yeah.
Uh what other projects do you have coming up?
Well I've got you know a whole uh set of them in various states of uh of development.
Uh since nineteen ninety I've been filming uh Native Americans I've got over I think forty forty five of them in the can of holographic portraits and full regalia with face paint and the whole nine yards.
And uh somehow I inspired uh uh Sharon McCormick to shoot one which is cool.
Mm-hmm.
I think she's done a few since then but that's always nice to see when you can inspire people to you know to do something.
And uh even if it's what you do it's you know if maybe they'll do it better, you know, you never know.
Mhm.
But uh but it that's it's it's a cool thing.
And uh so those are those are shot.
Um I started putting together the elements for a documentary and uh that's why I threw up the so called Holaroid.
So if anybody wants to see the old geezer of holography when they were younger, uh they can go to my website and look at that five too.
You know what I'm talking about, Frank?
Uh yes.
No, I did not click on that to tell you the truth.
I was sitting here thinking that's one of the first places I'm gonna go as soon as I hang this phone up.
Yeah, so called Holaroids.
I used to shoot Fulward photographs, uh I was kinda known as the the documaniac for a while and uh because I used to shoot video and skills and all kinds of stereograms of holograms and I've got a whole you know collection of this stuff which I really would like to put together as a uh as a little D V D or some kind of presentation where people can delve into it as deep as they want.
Would make a nice C D ROM.
There's a number of C D ROM projects out there right now for historical Hawaii I know George is doing one in Canada if he's not done already.
And uh I've heard of that and uh uh I know that there was some documentary shot on the West Coast and the Galverseutors had done something.
Yeah which I haven't gotten to screen yet myself but I'm I'm anxious to one day and you have a couple video clips on the website you know from that from one of the past shows that excellent.
Well I have a lot of this uh you know sort of rare footage and people's laboratories and uh some of the like forest stuff and um things that uh places that don't exist anymore and some cases sadly people who don't exist anymore.
Um uh and so it's going to be very interesting to cull this into um a story that is uh it's documentary but somehow um entertaining as well, you know.
You'll find that when you look through that collection of Polaroids, uh everyone seems to be smiling a lot.
I mean everybody's just so darn happy and um uh so uh uh what I'm hoping to capture in this video is, you know, what was it that that made them all so darn happy at the time.
You know.
Were you happy at the time when you were taking the pictures?
Oh yeah.
Maybe just rubbed off on them.
That's no there was there was a certain spirit which uh I don't know if it's been dampened uh well certainly in some of the individuals involved but hopefully not in the uh youngsters.
But uh uh uh there's a certain spirit of discovery and uh uh the unknown, uh exploring the unknown that that that is just man makes you wanna you know wake up in the morning or in the night and jump in a lab and and and see, you know, what will come forth.
And uh and this is a